what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
kendra g before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i am trying to move to
england
as you guys know there have been some
unexpected costs let me tell you um
anyways so every subscriber helps so
please help your girl out help your girl
out
okay
here you
go so what kind of men are you looking
for
um
also side note i have no idea who this
lady is but it's kind of like
a kevin samuels style show where like
girls will call in to her she's nine
months so where's her father what's
going on with you guys
um he's in the hospital so
yeah he's been he's very ill so i'm
looking for like a stepfather
wait
so you broke up with him why is in the
hospital
no i
no i didn't break up with him
were y'all not together when he went to
the hospital
yeah we we're still together
wait wait okay i'm looking for like uh
you know just in case
did she
did she just say just in case
i don't
the more i watch these the harder and
harder time
i'm having
like defending with like how am i
supposed to
how am i supposed to defend this and say
this is okay how am i
a stepfather just in case just in case
if he passes away
right
are you serious
yes kendra you have to have one in the
chamber kendra come on now
boy shouldn't you be holding him down
why is he in the hospital i can't i
can't go to the hospital because it's
like you know all the hospitals are shut
down
okay but
shouldn't you be waiting to see like is
it not looking good
it's not looking good
are you a comedian
no
kid no kendra i'm not a comedian
oh yeah
this is serious i'm serious
[Music]
i'm sorry i shouldn't be laughing
i should have kept i shouldn't be
laughing like that's wrong
but i just i can't believe this is real
i can't
like wha
and she's smiling she's like yeah yeah
he's in the hospital
he might pass away i hope
she might as well just say like this is
the outcome she wants we have a type of
relationship that's like
we're
very realistic my husband is much older
than me as well how old is your husband
um
he's 65 he'll be 66 in
a month or less a little bit less than a
month
how old are you
thirty-two
well i hope you surprised and i hope you
too and then i hope he divorces your ass
because i hope he survives and then
leaves you because any wife of his
that's i'm the real guy while you stay
in the hospital i'm a really good life
to him though you're a really good wife
as you're looking for a person while
he's still in the hospital bed
this is crazy but girl hey do you
okay all right bye baby hi
girl
i'm a
i'm i'm a good wife to him
don't don't
don't men value like i don't know
loyalty
uh maybe i'm maybe i'm tripping i don't
know
now that's a bull right there let me
just say how i really want to feel
that's some trifling
true now granted the age difference
is crazy okay
the age difference is crazy so we're
gonna start there but i'm giving damn
you don't be looking for no other man
while your whole husband is lit up in
the hospital now i know you can't move
forward but you should be doing prayers
asking guys to save your husband not on
instagram with kendra g
looking for a new man take care of you
ladies that's some trifecta right there
wait you should
like let the man die
let him die first
like like let the funeral happen
she's gonna be like getting numbers
at the funeral like look at looking at
his friends
because you know rich people know rich
people right let's say you're not work
as you're not worth
oh my god can you imagine she's gonna be
like at the funeral
i'm so sad but i'm single
i'm single now
so who's available
like get out of here all right guys let
me know in the comments
i i can't even imagine anyone thinks
this okay and this is okay but you know
if you do let me know i guess
please subscribe please please